welcome to this episode of programming
unit remember if you relate to any of
these you win so that's our goal let's
see if we can get some good humor and
interject novice programmer first
experienced programmer well I'm in the
way let me move myself yeah yeah I'll be
right here
I can't believe it worked the first time
I can't believe it worked the first time
yeah that doesn't really ever change
honestly there's always gonna be
something ok I'm not laughing but oh oh
did I relate I don't think I really did
cuz it's like this one doesn't count
it just doesn't count don't don't ask me
why ok
Python how am I so good at this I've
never written code before ok hmm boy
bullet on hit health minus equals random
range 535 Devon 4-0 references Wow yeah
you messed up okay in case you don't get
it should say you should have the health
here not producing another random rate
range it's just always fun girl I don't
know it's a humorous about that it's
just an error someone messed up oh boy
let's post it to programmer humor we
okay yeah okay we just said get up yeah
okay
they're not the same type of website at
all I was this programming human say
it's the most satisfying feeling in the
world following P for long hours yeah
sex is cool but you ever finally found a
bug and deleted all your print
statements at once that is true that is
very nice
and Stephanie very nice but did I don't
know I didn't relate forget it
that was to pierce this hurts are so
true
I thought you'd do anything just badly
is it is it just badly sometimes it's
not just badly okay cheese I know he's
not very excited when we just going okay
to hold him but seriously I got to stop
closing them before I talk about the
keys it's like the ravine not a good
strat here's a good strap let's read
this that's this one use package capture
room you're not a robot
please retype the code from the image
yeah good luck with that good luck with
that
hey this one was there last week what
can it go away now you stop why is it
still on the top refactoring refractors
code base to sporting furniture at just
one more piece of spaghetti
oh god Jen ever late is it really no I
didn't I don't think so I think I would
try this one probably so we're gonna
we're gonna go with not relating I don't
want WebDAV was better than MLA I tell
me please to get up here quick
somethings about to get shot I love this
response and everything but I don't know
what that is
I don't do that stuff I don't do web dev
or MLA guy so I wouldn't know thus I
can't relate it's not funny
British people unite system growing coal
or coal or why is this a program anyway
so what people from Britain sometimes
does it matter why is this some
programmer humor
this strand of thread is very satins
this whole reddit subreddit is very sad
and I know that responses will so are
you okay fine but I'm sad because of
your subreddit that's that's why I'm sad
right now okay
some probably proposed this and got shut
down by the Martinez marketing team why
did they call it
Airbnb when they could have called it a
localhost she has an awful website that
shows leaked versions of the web app so
right
still working on sending a cease and
desist order good one James
mistre almost relate it's funny
something funny funny so that's good hey
have enough turning off off trending
notifications and I'm trying to notice
press the bell icon next to subscribe
button on the subreddit on page consider
this being a subreddit mostly for
programmers I'm not surprised you keep
notes that is a joke now the post should
be able to stay here already two jokes
the third I suppose does more jokes than
useful information okay honey it's not
funny it's not really a joke someone
making some statements who cares
alright I should just call these I don't
know programming who cares
cuz that's what they end up being it's
like why are there never any funny ones
alright that's it I don't think I
related again I think I lost did I did
you lose did you win or did you lose so
I I didn't make it
alright well maybe next time we can
succeed
you know a couple of those almost go
almost turns like so close so close okay
until next time go eat some walnuts